i'd love everybody to pray for greg that
would be
beautiful um pray for his strength
nene leakes's husband greg leaks is
battling cancer again
the former real housewives of atlanta
star revealed that her husband
is currently in the hospital after his
cancer returned
and he had to undergo surgery during an
instagram live conversation with the
jasmine brand on monday
he's in the hospital um yeah
he's in the hospital he's been in the
hospital uh tomorrow will be a week
i haven't talked publicly about that
since the first time i'm saying
something about it
so yeah he's in the hospital he's been
there a week
tomorrow um i'm sure he'll be home
in about a week or so he had to have a
surgery
so his cancer did return in 2018 greg
was diagnosed with
stage 3 colon cancer however the cancer
went into remission for a time
after treatment he's had this surgery
before and
he was i think in the hospital about 15
days
nene said the situation has been quote
difficult
and that the battle has led to a change
in her husband
explaining that he is super small i'd
love everybody to pray for greg
that would be beautiful pray for his
strength
he prayed for me too back in may 2019
mimi opened up to e.t about sharing
greg's battle with cancer on real
housewives
what was it like to get the response
from the fans and the viewers for maybe
going through the same thing you and
greg and your family is going well i can
say that i had a lot of fans to reach
out to me
caretakers were emailing me left and
right saying we understand what you are
going through
now there were people who did not
understand what a caretaker
role is or they just didn't understand
me saying i was frustrated they were
like why are you frustrated you're not
the one like half there
but you know i i was frustrated because
i was a caretaker and being a caretaker
is hard it's one of those roles where
you just don't get any shine for that
you know you just be a caretaker and
shut up
and the tv personality gave an update on
greg's health at the time
my husband was diagnosed with stage 3
colon cancer
and so ever since then we have been all
over this whole cancer thing
because it was devastating to our family
but i'm happy to say today
that greg is much better we don't know
if he's free of cancer
but he's much better that was going to
be my next question how is greg doing
today and how are you and greg doing
today greg and i are doing good
uh greg is doing great he took a body
scan
i think two days ago a pet scan to see
if there's any cancer in his body if it
had spread
anywhere and he'll get the results next
week all right so
fingers crossed and then i know he's
good he looks good
he lost weight and the weight he lost it
looks amazing on him so i know he's good
a few days later nene and greg took to
instagram to celebrate the first time he
beat cancer
sharing this snap of greg holding a sign
that read
no cancer found praise god nene
captioned the post quote
look at god we are overjoyed to say we
saw the doctors for the results of
greg's pet scan he took last week
test show wait for it we are cancer-free
you